Female Commentator: So from Breathless
to the team of the work of champions,
from a classical music singer to
a contemporary music composer
today we have him here in new shoes
of an entrepreneur and a music teacher.
IGN proudly presents Shankar Mahadevan.
[applause and cheering]
Shankar: Good evening everybody.
There's not a single day that goes by
without remembering you all -- [laughter]
because I can't believe that
I am at THE Google office.
Thank you very much
for making this happen.
[applause and cheering]
Really.
It's truly a new experience
and an honor for me
and it's so lovely to meet you all, all of you here.
I think before I start talking
why don't I just sing a song for you?
What do you think?
[cheering and applause]
Shankar Mahadevan: [unintelligible]
[laughter]
Aren't you, haven't you heard
that every day during the match?
Okay I'll sing for that later.
I'll definitely sing that for you.
Yeah?
Okay, right now I'll just
since it's such an auspicious beginning
I'll just do a little prayer for you, okay?
[Shankar Mahadevan singing]
♪ Ah... ♪
♪ oh, um ♪
[singing in Hindi]
[applause and cheering]
Shankar Mahadevan: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
This is a new venture,
a new front which I had along
with a few friends of mine.
I finished my engineering,
I was also became an engineer
but it was [unintelligible].
And an engineering college mate
of mine Sridhar Ranganathan
we met after 15 years.
He was here in the Bay Area
for 15 years,
hated it but he formed his company,
he sold it, he's made his money.
And I did my little bit in music,
composing, singing,
whatever you'll have heard
some of the stuff that I've done.
After 15 years we met
because I always wanted
to do something in teaching;
teaching Indian music
to people all over the world.
And Sridhar was even thinking
of developing something,
a platform for education.
So we thought of something,
we came together,
and we formed this Shankar Mahadevan
Academy online
so that we can teach music
to all of you,
at your pace, at your convenience,
in your house.
So I'd like to welcome
my friend and my partner,
the CEO of Shankar Mahadevan Academy,
Sridhar Ranganathan.
[applause]
Sridhar Ranganathan: Hello, yeah.
Thanks Shankar.
I lived here almost 13 and a
half 14 years and I was at Yahoo,
pre-Google days, I'd like
to qualify that. [laughter]
Because the buzz and excitement that
you guys have here it was the same thing
but nine years I've been doing Yahoo.
I went to Bangalore to set
up the Yahoo R & D Center.
What I found there was a lot of
educated people coming through,
but we had to to through like a 110,
115 resumes and I see a friend here,
[inaudible], was with me there;
100, 110 resumes to get one person.
What I found was that
education system goes one way,
you learn somewhere else,
and then we all make a career of it in
spite of education system sometimes.
And then that's one of the things
that really stayed with me.
I wanted to find a way to
make it happen differently.
With the advent of Flash, video, audio,
and all, YouTube, whatever right.
And you have so much content and you
guys know this better in a lot of ways
is searching for that needle
in the haystack that hits you
and that's what you guys try to do.
The whole idea about how do you
find that needle in the haystack
to help you understand
and then how we find that
related needle in the haystack
and those are some of the algorithms
that you guys are working probably.
What we did was we tried to overlay
a pedagogic template on top of it.
What kind of a learner are you?
Are you a visual learner,
as you a auditory learner,
as you a kinesthetic learner,
and all these different things.
And kind of overlay a template on it
and see how we can create
a content management system
that would help you as a student learn;
help a teacher to teach a class.
So as we're along this journey
and then Shankar was thinking that,
"Okay I want to create a music academy
in the suburbs of Bombay,
build a building
and then as soon as in the first
five minutes of when we met
academy online platform
breaking the boundaries,
all these things started
just coming up for it.
We jammed for a bit,
there you go,
within about six months we had
to actually launched academy online
on 3rd of March which happens
to be Shankar's birthday.
And in the last month,
five weeks we have 100 plus students.
So it just, all of those things
just happened, click.
So what I wanna talk to you
today about is what it is,
how to you learn, what is so new,
what is so unique,
what is different about this.
So we have three fundamental things
and Shankar will talk more about that in
terms of the curriculum of Indian music.
If you go to good western music
you start with sheet music,
you have prerequisite,
you have course one,
course two, course three,
you know what your journey is,
how you progress in
your career to learn music.
In Indian classical music usually
it's up to the teacher to decide,
it's up to you how to learn,
there is no specific course work and
there's no specific assessments.
You can't really take advantage
of technology that is there today
that we can use.
The second part is so we actually structured
the curriculum and the course work.
So you have 16 courses,
four beginners, 16 intermediate,
sorry, four beginners,
six intermediate,
six advanced where you get
a diploma or a degree.
We are working with reputed colleges
to even make it available as a credit
when you go to colleges and such.
The second part is a online
music book and short poem book
where we tried to capture the content
in all the multimedia facets:
video, audio, and such and
also integrate tools in it.
For example, if Shankar is playing music
on the iTanpura app on the his iPhone.
We actually integrate that
we'll plan to integrate in there.
We have a recorder where you
actually practice and sing
and submit your assignment
in the audio
and the teacher gives you feedback
in audio again.
So we'll demonstrate that and pixel it.
And then you can save a recording,
you can share it with your friends,
you can [inaudible ] with your family,
you can do a lot of those kind of things.
And trying of see
how you can push the envelope
in terms of learning, enjoying it,
making it fun for everybody.
The third part is real simple and I don't
want to reinvent technology there
we just integrated WebEx on the back.
One click you're in a class,
one teacher to five students.
We keep the class small
and teach and learn.
With that I'll introduce
one of our students,
[inaudible].
She's been in the Academy
for the last five weeks
and she'll demonstrate to you
how she learns from the online music.
Sridhar Ranganathan: I think
you should speak here. Yep.
Sridhar Ranganathan: You want this?
Female Student: Good evening everyone,
So my name is [inaudible].
I'm an engineer like most of you.
I've been with Intel for many,
many years and I took today off,
I'm not bunking and --
[laughter] favor
because I wanted to really
help out this wonderful team
and share with you my
experience at the Academy.
I'm very fortunate I found
about it on day one
or maybe a few days before
and I signed up right away.
And it's been a wonderful experience.
Before I introduce you to the different
tools that I use as a student
I would like to just share
with you a quick background.
I've always been drawn to music
and throughout my life I've tried
taking classes off and on.
My first memory of taking Hindustani
classical was when I was in fifth grade,
and of course it was not
my idea but my mom's idea.
She thought it was a good idea
to put me in school
so in Lucknow she put me
in one of the best schools in India
and here as a fifth grader all I wanted
to do was sing fun songs right
because nobody wants to listen to sarigama.
And I go to this class where I'm the
youngest children and for six months,
five days a week
all I was taught was Sarigama,
Sarigama Padanisa, Sarigama Padanisa.
The assumption was one size fits all.
They take six months
for everybody to learn that
and that's what's they're going to teach you.
So you can imagine how exciting that was.
Not quite.
And the second part was you could not
discuss Bollywood music with your teachers
because these teachers were old schoolers
and Bollywood music was
considered as very light.
So then not surprising year dropped out .
So I took lessons off and on and then
my last experience was in Bay Area
actually I would drive 40 minutes for a class
and I won't like to name the school.
I mean the teachers are excellent
except that I was the only woman in the class
and some of you might know
that men have a different scale,
women have a different scale,
and the whole class was singing
at the scale of these men.
So I could never quite keep up because it's
almost like you're asking [speaks Hindi].
And every time I would
bring it up with my teacher
she was really catering to the other students
so it was extremely demotivating
for me, right?
All these years I thought I was
an okay singer of this film music
and here I was unable to
even keep up with the class.
So I again dropped out.
The day I found out about this Academy,
I mean, that very evening I signed up.
And why?
Let me be honest with you,
that it had Shankar's name in it.
I'm one of his biggest fans and like
I have experienced taking classes,
dropping out.
How bad can it be?
And Shankar has his name in
the Academy like we just joined.
And it's been a wonderful
experience for me
and hopefully you'll see some
of the process that I go through.
So when I log into the Academy
these are the options I see.
So there's a virtual class I think
Sridhar talked about once every week
on Thursday for half an hour.
All I have to do is click on join class
and it opens this WebEx conference.
I can see the other four students and the
teacher and it's a very interactive class.
The teacher actually introduces
you to a new concept,
it's very structured.
He tells you what is expected,
what assignments are
expected for next week,
and what he's going to be
covering next week, okay?
So then the last five minutes
of the class time [inaudible]
you spend discussing about
all the Bollywood songs
that are based on that particular
Ragg or similar [inaudible]
which is actually always been
interesting to me
because it gives you a different
level of music appreciation.
When you listen to a song
automatically then you start thinking,
"Oh my God," the more you learn
it's very gratifying.
So then also you have recorded class
so if for some reason
you've missed a class
you can actually every class is recorded
you can go back and listen to it.
Even if you haven't missed,
listening to yourself actually highlights
all kinds of problems
that you might be totally unaware of.
And then the last is the OM Book which
is actually the most valuable resource
that is available to you.
[pause]
This is a book which has
very rich audio video content.
So I'm sure here most of you must
have heard about this Alcon Academy,
all the learning happens offline
and then through the interaction
you actually are discussing,
the concepts are getting reinforced.
So here there are these online videos,
short videos where you learn.
I mean you listen to it as many time
as it takes to understand
because it's available to you
for four hours a day.
And when you feel that you're ready
then there is a little tool right there
I can press record, I can sing,
and then I stop and play back;
if I'm satisfied I save it and I submit.
And that's my assignment submitted at one
goal and the teacher provides feedback
if I sang great or not.
So in the OM Book
there are teacher's notes,
very detailed notes,
there's no excuse to say I forgot
that there's an assignment due
because it's all captured here,
what assignments are due
after what class.
And then also the chapters if you see like I
think Shankar mentioned it's very structured.
I know that once I get out
of this course 12 weeks later
I will know a small Bandish
and Raag Yaman.
And that chapter in Raag Yaman actually
also has several Bollywood compositions
that are based on Raag Yaman
so I'll have a little more in depth
knowledge of Raag Yaman.
So let me demonstrate this is one
of the Alankars that we learned.
There's a very famous singer,
[inaudible] who's singing
but this is what I would on an evening I
would listen to this Alankar for example.
[woman singing in Hindi]
Okay so this is one of the first
few Alankars you learn.
So I have an iPhone app which I connect
to my amplifier and at my scale
and go to that.
Everybody sings at their own scales,
you don't have to sing
at somebody else's scale.
I sing the same Alankar and I submit
and I'll give you a quick demonstration.
I submitted this assignment.
So look at how many assignments
I have been submitted in four weeks,
you'll be impressed.
[laughter]
This is only one page.
male in audience: That's a lot.
Well, these are assignments recordings
is what I want to do.
These are the number of recordings
I have submitted.
[female singing]
This is right here and the
teacher provides feedback.
Male Teacher: [inaudible] sung
once again you have a really bold
and open voice --
Female Speaker: He spotted
something else bold and open voice.
Male Teacher: it was also fine
and it was very relaxing,
and it was sung in a very comfortable
pace and [inaudible].
Good job.
female student: So I picked one
that was good. [laughter]
There is also ones that I got [inaudible]
in that case he sings it and says,
"This is where you made a mistake."
Sings it wrong like you did and then say,
"No that should be done this way."
So very customized and
detailed feedback.
So again just two minutes on
what I like about the Academy.
First of all you sing at your own scale.
I think I made that point again and again
because I think that itself keeps a lot
of us from taking such classes.
Second ,its self-paced.
So if a certain concept is difficult
you can listen to it more,
number of times and you don't
have to follow it and it's customized.
So the teacher really knows where each
student is at even for the same Alankar
the students can be challenged
very differently.
I mean the teachers are so great
that after the second class
the teacher understands
where everybody is at.
So everybody's getting
challenged from differently.
If you're traveling like I am,
this week I'm going to be in Oregon,
I can join the class from
where ever I am
or if you're not traveling too
so that of course goes without saying.
And last but not the least
which has been a complete unexpected
positive development that I've seen.
I have two boys 11 and 13,
they've been learning the piano,
they've been learning guitar
and drums for many, many years.
I know they are somewhat musical
by now after all these years.
If I ask them to take classical music,
I mean Hindustani music I mean
they wouldn't do it.
They're, you have to catch them young
so we missed that window of opportunity.
But every evening when I am practicing,
it's in the living room,
they're sitting on their laptops
and very often I've heard my oldest son sing
the same Alankars and he's perfectly in tune.
So he doesn't even know that he's singing,
he'll be humming
and of course I'll be as quiet as possible
because the moment I point out he'd stop.
So just knowing that these kids
are getting exposed to something
that matters so much to me
is so gratifying,
and I think it will help him
become a better musician
even if it's a Western one if he wants to.
But that's my story.
[applause]
Shankar Mahadevan: So to sum it up,
basically, what we've tried to do is
whether we would learn anything
in any institute
anything that you're learning you receive
your knowledge through two sources:
one is your book, your textbook
or whatever book that is there.
That is available to you 24/7,
you can refer to the book
anytime you want.
That's why we have created
a digital textbook for,
you can look at that and
you can practice with it.
It's a self-learning tool because the way
we have shot the videos it's in great detail
and there are rotations that you can just
take a print out of the references,
there are YouTube links,
there are so many things available
in that one textbook
and there's a lot of theory over there.
Especially for children,
for small children we are having very
interesting things like animation
and little games for them
so that identification of the [inaudible]
they can do using these games.
There's one little beep that comes out
and you are to identify what note that is
and you burst that particular thing.
So they get what is called a sarva
or we teach them simple things,
simple songs that they've already
heard in their lives like
[singing in Hindi to the tune of
Twinkle, Twinkle Little Star].
So they relate it to the tune
that they've heard
and somehow subconsciously
they learn Sarvagan.
So that is using the OM Book,
that is the online music book,
we've got the name OM Book for that.
And of course the teacher that is
available in any institute similarly
we have a live teacher over there
and he works with the class
but that is at a specified time,
you have to be there, log on,
and you learn your
whatever you're learning.
So that's it basically.
Sridhar Ranganathan: So there's
a teacher here
and she's gonna conduct
a class with you guys.
Shankar Mahadevan: Yeah and I want
all of you to sing with us okay?
Sridhar Ranganathan: Are you ready?
I thought I heard you.
Shankar Mahadevan: Come
on Google are you ready?
audience in unison: Yes.
Shankar Mahadevan: Superb.
Padma is, go ahead.
Padma Shankar: Hi.
Shankar Mahadevan: This Padma
Shankar from Chennai.
Okay --
Sridhar Ranganathan: Let's have a loud round
of applause for Padma Shakar because --
[applause]
she's right now, right now
in Chennai and firstly
because it 4:30 in the morning --
[laughter] and she's up.
Thank you very much Padma for that.
And also she's been with us
from the conceptualization stage
from the time we had our free pilot,
we got her for a free pilot,
then we did a pilot
and we did a paid pilot.
All this time she was there with us
and a couple of people like her.
So thank you very much Padma.
And what are you going to make us sing?
I think you should, I think looking at the crowd
they should do a Bollywood song.
What do you think?
Okay.
members of audience
shouting out: Yeah, yeah,
Shankar Mahadevan: I read their minds.
[laughter]
Padma Shankar: Since [inaudible] achieved
our status I'm in India
and I'm with all these Google guys there.
I will be teaching you a [inaudible].
Are you ready to sing with me?
Shankar Mahadevan: Yes, yes, yes.
Padma Shankar: [singing in Hindi]
Shankar Mahadevan: Three, four.
audience: [singing in Hindi]
Padma Shankar: [singing in Hindi]
Shankar Mahadevan: Can you make it
a little bit louder?
audience: [singing in Hindi]
Padma Shankar: [singing in Hindi]
Padma Shankar: Now together with me.
Padma Shankar and audience: [singing in Hindi]
Shankar Mahadevan: Fantastic!
Thank you very much Padma!
[applause]
This is not Google, this is surreal a Google.
[laughter]
Fantastic Padma.
Thanks Padma.
Shankar Mahadevan: So what
we did was not only,
not everybody wants to wear
a coat and tie and put a shawl
and become a pundit and
do a classical music concert.
So there are many, many, many of us
who just want to experience
the joy of singing
and just enjoy singing simple songs
that I always [speaking in Hindi].
So we designed these hobby
singing courses for people
who just want to learn simple songs.
So we went and we put a poll and
we got a lot of feedback saying
that we would like to learn
this song that song
so we are in a continuous process of developing
these OM Books for every single song,
different songs sung by artists
like you may wanna learn [inaudible], you
may wanna learn [inaudible], whatever.
So we're designing these
OM Books for simple,
I think those are short courses
they're not intense courses
like in Hindustani and Carnatic music.
They'll be lasting for just
four weeks, a month.
In a month you learn the song completely
and those OM Books have detailed,
they've got lyrics,
they've got [inaudible],
the way you sing it,
the tune, the inflections,
everything is explained by the teacher.
Sridhar Ranganathan: And is example
of Shankar teaching one of his songs --
Shankar Mahadevan: I'm
not using all the songs,
this song I'm teaching --
Sridhar Ranganathan: we're launching
this song on May 8th
which happens to be the Mother's Day
and the song was aptly named Maa.
Sridhar Ranganathan: So
I'll show you a small?
audience: Oooh.
I'll show you a small sample of how
he teaches the [inaudible] One and --
Sridhar Ranganathan: Now when you
arrive at the [inaudible] bridge
as we can call it for this song
that is when your singing has to be very--
as you can see not bold,
that is volume wise
it has to be the loudest in your entire
rendition of your song.
Because that is the part
when you're actually,
you're discussing something
that you have visualized before
and something you should happen to you
and how you used to look at--
look for your mother's help.
So it's a little bit of an anxiety
kind of a feeling in this bridge.
So I just demonstrate
how you do it.
[Indian music in background]
And that is where if you know
in the song the drums also kick in
and the guitar chords now come in
so that's where the song as such
becomes slightly louder than your [inaudible].
The vocal is very silent and
just the guitar and the piano.
So.
Um.
[singing in Hindi]
We'll do it to here.
So there's a particular graph to this,
the notes of this are: da,
da, da, da.
But it's a move.
Da, da, da, da.
One step up.
Then I go one step down.
Da, da, da, da.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
I want you to be very careful while singing
this melody is the pitching of the notes.
Where are the notes, there are notes
that you sing very straight
and you repeat it very straight
so your pitch them very carefully.
So, so ♪ da, da, da, da. ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da. ♪
So first time it is straight,
♪ da, da, da. ♪
Second of there's a little slur,
♪ da, da, da, da. ♪
[singing in Hindi]
A slight
slur leading to that note.
[singing in Hindi]
This maa has to be almost
be like the volume button
that you have in your television set
just because da, da, da and
it ends at a particular part.
♪ Maa. ♪
But this is not a cut thing like
how you [speaking in Hindi].
This has to sustain and also fade out.
Maa.
[singing in Hindi]
After reaching that volume you have to
come down to a softer volume again.
[singing in Hindi]
Now this [speaking in Hindi] has
to be a little bit of a desperation;
a looking out for somebody.
It can't be [singing in Hindi].
You're searching for somebody.
[singing in Hindi]
So coming back
[singing in Hindi].
Sridar
Ranganathan: That's a sample of this.
So here this is like video number 20
and things so there's a lot of things
that go before that and like he breaks
it down to small, small pieces.
The idea is to make it enjoyable,
fun, and learn it.
Maybe you can ask him
to sing the whole song.
[audience cheering and clapping]
Shankar Mahadevan: That was
a Goggeling a Google.
[laughter]
[singing in Hindi]
[applause]
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
[applause]
Once again thank you
for having us over here.
I hope you all enjoyed
what we presented to you
and I hope some of you'll be in part of this
journey that we have started together.
Sridhar Ranganathan: Okay,
so we can tell [inaudible].
The idea is to create
something that is fun,
enjoyable for everybody and that's
really what we're trying to do here.
We can take some questions if you
have about the Academy and such and--
Yeah?
male #1: So this schedule
that [inaudible].
Shankar Mahadevan: [inaudible]
male #1: Can you tell the pitch [inaudible]
Shankar: It's all there.
All the pitch and everything that he gives
on the page the śruti because that it,
you just saw a part of the video isn't it
so she explains the page
what śruti she's using
and you can learn in turn in your pitch.
male #1: [inaudible]
Shankar Mahadevan: Yes.
Shankar Mahadevan: She'll be able to
explain better how she managed it.
female student So the teacher has
[inaudible] but when he comes to me
he actually remembers what my scale is
so he brings it down,
I sing, and he moves on to the next one,
he remembers what that person's pitch is.
[Inaudible] don't need to tune, right?
So people are singing at their own pitch.
male #1: [Inaudible ]
female student: Yes.
Five students are never singing together.
Shankar Mahadevan: They're all there,
they're hearing the other students sing,
but they never sing together.
So each one can sing in their own
pitch and while the other students,
my teacher used to tell me that
it's much better to learn in a group
but not in a group of twenty.
It's always better to learn
in a group of four or five
because if you're learning alone
you start feeling that you have
arrived very soon.
When you hear other students sing
you know [laughter] where you stand.
So when you're in a class of four
or five you hear the other students,
they inspire you.
Not only that if student number
one, two, three, four,
you're the first student automatically
there's a kind of a [Hindi word]
that happens five times.
Then you shuffle the metering
the one, two, three
and then five, four, three, two, one
then three, two, five, four, one.
So you just juggle the order
and you're learning already.
And when it comes to you
if you're uncomfortable
in the normal class of the pitch,
pitch of the class you bring the pitch
down to your particular pitch
and you practice in that.
female #1: Could you say like how
your [inaudible] issues
when I go to a class it that [unintelligible]
so much more experienced right?
[inaudible] How do you sort of find a fit
for the students and the teacher and --
Sridar Ranganathan: So let me answer
that wonderful questions in there.
So the first thing is when you enroll
you'll see there's a age bracket
and then there's a gender bracket.
So we try to group people who can
sing and based on age and gender.
The second part is the quarters
are structured 101, 102, 103, 104
and then it goes 201 to 206,
and 301 to 306,
which means you have
a diagnostic assessment.
If you think you'll learn something earlier
and then you want to see where you belong
you submit assessment
and the teacher says,
"Okay you belong in 103 or 104 or
102 or you actually start from 101
because what you've learned is wrong,"
or whatever it is.
And then most of the people that we are
seeing now actually start in 101, right?
And then there the grouping's already done
and then during the class again
like I've talked about earlier
where we are trying to make this
as personal as is possible,
give enough materials
personal to you to learn.
We also try to group students
into okay these guys are okay,
these guys are better,
and these guys are the best.
And then we try to give materials how to
move the okay into better and the best.
So are particular ways of looking at this.
Did I answer your question?
Yeah, okay, good.
female #2: So what is like the starting age
that you recommend for kids?
Shankar Mahadevan: See kids are
damn fast in grasping things
whether they understand it or don't understand
it they just learn stuff really fast.
So I think the minute you find out that
your kid has an inclination towards music
or he reacts to music,
I think you can start playing some music
in your house already,
something that you feel that will
be comfortable in your environment
and if it's a South Indian environment
people like to listen to Carnatic music
or whatever or [inaudible] or whatever.
And they keep on listening to it
subconsciously a lot of it goes in to it.
That's my experience.
My father used to do a Pooja
at four or five in the morning
and all the slokars I remembered suddenly now
when I was doing some project I said,
"How do I know this slokars?"
And I remembered that those are
the slokars which my father used to do
when I was a very small kid.
So they can start at a very early age.
I mean basic learning five, five and
a half, four, four and a, whatever.
Some kids are really sharp so
they can start at a very early age.
Sridar Ranganathan: Also the language
part so at three and four and five
they actually pick up the language
through the music much faster
because they don't really distinguish
a different language as much.
So it's much easier to different
languages at that point in time.
Shankar Madadevan: And currently we just
we have students who are also about 70?
Sridar Ranganathan: Three.
Shankar Madadevan: 73 year old
also so that is the range,
bandwidth.
[laughter]
Yeah.
male #2: Thanks for coming to Google --
Shankar Madadevan: Thanks.
male #2: it's good to have you here.
[inaudible]
Shankar Madadevan: You wanna answer that?
Sridar Ranganathan: Yeah, so we started we
actually started our pre-pilot with the violin
and then we, so the only music
book part is easy right
but when it comes to WebEx what happens
is you have the bow and the fingers,
finger movement,
there is a couple of challenges there.
You probably need two cameras or
if you go take a tabla two cameras.
Actually the worst is, the most extreme
is like a [inaudible] or a dohl right,
two hands.
Now if you put the camera in the front
you can't see either, right?
You have to put two cameras.
So we're experimenting it, we really
are working on the curricular part of it.
But then how do you give the method of
instruction in a live class is working on.
So the answer is yes
it's coming [inaudible].
Even the piano, for example, is broad.
Now how to you have multiple cameras
for that, and things like that?
male #2: [inaudible] [laughter]
Shankar Madadevan: You know a friend
of mine is already a sitar hero in India
and his name is Niladri Kumar.
Have you heard him?
He's truly a sitar hero,
he plays the distortion sitar.
He's a rock star, yeah.
Yeah but definitely the thing is
we always believe in crawl, walk,
and run kind of thing.
So we wanted to do it properly,
we wanted to establish this platform nicely
so that we know that the formula
is there and that the OM Book,
the virtual class, the curriculum,
everything it flows one after the other.
We tried for the pre-pilot,
then the pilot,
then the paid pilot.
So it worked very smoothly.
So for vocal we just started for vocal,
Carnatic, Hindustani,
hobby singing, devotional, chanting,
all these things are starting up now.
But definitely all the instruments
are coming up.
But whenever we do that
we will again do a pre-pilot,
a pilot, and the paid pilot,
and then you wanna follow that
so that we are doubly sure
that when we launch so we don't
have complaints coming in.
Sridar Ranganathan: Yeah it's like
that Carnatic music [speaking Hindi]
and then the popular [speaking Hindi].
So we kind of follow
the same concept: quality first,
his name is on the Academy
you wanna make sure
what you do is right and proper.
female #3: So I'm [inaudible]
but my friend says that for me [inaudible].
Sridar Ranganathan: So we
try to make the best fit.
So here's the thing right, if as a consumer
if you try to choose
when you actually don't know
what it is,
it gets harder to manage that
from even a scaling perspective.
So we try to make sure that
you have the right teacher.
And we also not only assess
at the end of 12 weeks
we also assess continuously
how they progress.
Like I said we give more materials.
So teacher is a part of that
more material resources
in terms of making sure
you have the right teacher.
So we manage it on the back and
we don't give you a choice
because you won't know anyway.
You just have a name,
you already know names.
Any other questions?
female #4: How many of the classes
is Shankar teaching?
Shankar Mahadevan: Well I don't come
into any of the classes and teach myself,
I come in as visiting faculty.
And not only me I have spoken to many,
many, many big artists Mahagurus of India
and they've all consented to come in.
So suddenly you'll see Rashid Khan coming in
or suddenly you'll see [inaudible] coming in
or suddenly you'll see
[inaudible] coming in
and giving a speech on his experiences.
So it's gonna be extremely motivating.
So we're gonna have a whole
range of people coming in
'cause you can't expect me to get up
every day morning at four o'clock
and teach 'til ten o'clock.
That's why we have chosen teachers, all
the teachers are chosen by my consent.
I have personally looked into
the selection process
so these teachers are extremely competent
and my thing is choosing all these things
and coming in once in a while.
Sridhar Ranganathan: And the teachers have
to go through a teacher's certification program.
Not only do they have to be good in music
they also have to have good
communication skills
given the market that
we are going after.
So it's very well choreographed
and planned.
Question?
Female Commentator: We can probably
take two more questions.
Sridhar Ranganathan: Okay.
Shankar Mahadevan: You are the boss.
[laughter]
male #3: A big welcome to you at Google
and thank you for your [inaudible].
Shankar Mahdevan: Thank you.
male #3: For kids and even for adults
who want to join the class
are there anything like camps where they
can sometimes meet the teacher in person
also like maybe the teacher
is visiting here
or I go to Chennai I meet the teacher there.
Are there any plans [inaudible] like that?
Sridhar Ranganthan: It's an Academy
we'll have annual programs,
contests, competitions.
Like I said we just started in March.
Shankar Mahadevan: It's just a month old,
we just started March 3rd but we have --
Sridhar Ranganathan: Absolutely.
Shankar Mahadevan: exciting plans.
Actually we have a student over here
who visited she is here?
commentator: Yeah, she just left.
Shankar Mahadevan: She just left, okay.
She got bored.
[laughter]
So definitely we want to connect
with the students
and if there is a spark in somebody
who's brilliant,
who shows brilliance there is
an upcoming music director
and he visiting so we can
definitely work with. [laughter]
Sridhar Ranganathan: Two more questions.
male in audience: She had her hand up.
female #6: While you are teaching
[inaudible] do you also have [inaudible] --
Shankar Mahadevan: Oh yeah how
can you not have,
it's like the four wheels of a car
they have to be of the correct pressure,
tire pressure, it's like that.
So taal as important as your
raag or śruti or anything.
So everything that is required
along with your śruti
especially when you learn Carnatic
music from the word go
they start doing this [speaking in Hindi]
every week corresponds to a note.
So it's done the proper way and
taal is as important as your śruti.
They say that [speaking in Hindi]
you can even start singing in [inaudible]
but if you're taal is really weak
from the time you're born
so might as well try agriculture or fishing -- [laughter] yeah.
Sridar Ranganathan: Or technology.
[laughter]
Shankar Mahadevan: Ah.
Sridar Ranganthan: Yeah.
male #4: So one of the long
term plans for the academy?
I see that there's a technology
aspect to [inaudible] --
Sridar Ranganthan: A what?
male #4: --a cost
so there's a cost
and most of the people outside of
here are I think would be okay that.
But for India do you
have some different plans?
Sridar Ranganthan: Yeah,
so in the two-pronged plans:
one is how do we work
with corporations and schools
in getting offline Shankar Mahadevan Academy
centers with probably our own centers.
So those are things like I said
by the time we build-- get a land,
build a building, do this that
and it takes a long time.
So but we will get definitely
online first,
but we have those plans.
In the online space of it it's key
that it's priced differently
so those are things that
we are working on for India.
Shankar Mahadevan: And soon we'll
be opening up to the rest of the world
so we'll be, just manage
the virtual class bit,
the timings and everything,
match accordingly,
we already have something called
they are acoustically designed boards
as we call it in Bangalore right now
where the teachers come and they sit
there and they have high speed Internet,
there's a camera,
there's a light everything.
So it's all organized right now.
But that is for the U.S.A.
So similarly there are logistics planned
it's a matter of just applying ourselves.
Sridar Ranganathan: There is a acoustic part
where you don't hear dogs barking
or crows -- [laughter]
Shankar Mahadevan: Traffic in Bombay's
is great now so. [laughter]
Sridar Ranganathan: We get one more question.
Last question.
Yeah.
female #7: [unintelligible]
This is amazing and I want to
thank you so much for being here.
Shankar Mahadevan: Thanks.
Sridar Ranganathan: Thanks.
female #7: What I especially liked [inaudible] entire demo
and you kind of [inaudible] everybody
and teach them.
It's kind of like the little like expressions
that you talk about,
the anxiety or just in general feeling
that you go deeper into a song
and so I was just really happy to see that
also being conveyed the electronic quality.
Shankar Madadevan: Okay boss [inaudible].
[laughter]
Sridar Ranganathan: Actually that is
an important point that you bring up.
See the thing is now you can buy a CD,
you can go to YouTube,
you can do so many places
where you can get the song.
What is the value,
why do you even do this?
We went through a lot of that sort
of thinking about it making sure
there is huge value for you
in learning the song.
This was started by Shankar
but then the same thing is done
for each song by different artists
who can actually help you
pick up the nuances,
the expressions, the emotions
that you connect and all that.
Thank you.
Shankar Mahadevan: Thank you very much.
Sridar Ranganathan: Thank you guys.
[applause]
commentator: If you wanna sign up
for the Academy
I guess [inaudible] so you can just--
Shankar Mahadevan: Hello.
I'll sing probably you sing with me.
Are you ready?
in unison: Yeah.
Shankar Mahadevan: I'll sing one line you're
allowed to sing [inaudible]. [laughter]
Okay I need the rhythm because I don't
have any instruments over here
so you're beat will be my rhythm.
Okay, one, two, three.
Come on.
[everyone clapping in rhythm]
Everybody.
[singing in Hindi]
[applause and cheering]
That was for India.
So let's hear it for [speaking in Hindi].
audience: Yea!
00:53:33.133,00:00:00.000